hallo und herzlich willkommen hier
zusammen live stream aus dem euro war
was für eine nacht wir sind bei den
scorpions und haben gewartet auf die
ergebnisse wie alle anderen wer hat die
nase vorn unter den
präsidentschaftskandidaten der
demokratischen partei mit mir ist
annette brieger unsere reporterin aus
dem studio in washington und wir wollen
ihre und eure fragen beantworten zu dem
was da passiert ist wir haben irgendwann
aufgegeben also wir haben unsere
beiträge gemacht für die sendungen
soweit wir sie machen konnten
mit ersten reaktionen was hier passiert
ist und dann haben wir uns entschlossen
wir gehen eine mütze schlaf nehmen damit
wir auch hier wieder fit sind
das war nicht zu erwarten dass die
ergebnisse dann so schnell hier rein
rollen und wir zeigen vielleicht einmal
kurz er was da in der vergangenen nacht
passiert ist und spielen ein beitrag
groß der andrang bei den sogenannten
kongress parteiversammlung in turnhallen
wie dieser stimmten die demokraten in
ihrer abwehr für sie ins rennen ums
weiße haus gehen soll
sie setzten sich in dem bereich ihres
kandidaten viele bis zum schluss
unentschieden die angstvolle frage wer
kann trump schlagen kann es wählbarkeit
ist das oberste ding für mich wenn ich
sehen würde jemand kommt er nicht an
dann könnte er die besten positionen der
welt haben ich würde mich nicht dorthin
setzen
jemand der gewinnen kann darum geht's
das steht für mich an nummer eins jemand
der tram schlagen kann
der korpus ein ritual das seltsam
anmutet die gruppen werden ausgezählt
nach der ersten runde
laut starke versuche die anhänger der
unterlegenen kandidaten zu gewinnen
stunden später keine ergebnisse eine
panne bei der auszählung das team joe
biden kritisiert in einem schreiben
erhebliche mängel im prozess von
kandidaten durchhalteparolen an die fans
wir wissen nicht was wir hier haben aber
wir fühlen uns gut wo wir stehen wir
sind hier auf der langstrecke
optimistischer klingt bernie sanders
beiden kontrahent vom linken flügel der
demokraten
wenn die ergebnisse mal bekannt gegeben
werden dann bin ich sicher dass wir sehr
sehr gut abschneiden werden hier neue
war offen wann die ergebnisse vorliegen
werden sollte den auftakt geben zu einem
langen wahlkampf dieser auftakt ist
misslungen so wir wissen jetzt ein
bisschen mehr von dem was da in der
nacht passiert ist
es ging um folgendes ganz offenbar hat
die demokratische partei hier in europa
eine app programmiert und es war gedacht
dass aus 1600 mehr als 1600 wahllokalen
dann die ergebnisse über diese app
gemeldet werden an die zentrale um dann
möglichst schnell eben sagen zu können
wer hat die nase vorn wer hat gewonnen
hier war von den
präsidentschaftskandidaten und das hat
ganz offenbar nicht funktioniert die app
hat versagt und dann ist folgendes
passiert man habe versucht per telefon
dann eben diese ergebnisse hier hinein
zu melden in die zentrale nach dem 1
und man kann sich vorstellen wenn 1600
chefs der einzelnen wahllokale das
versuchen dass da eine ganz lange
warteschlange ist und jeder einzelne
will seine ergebnisse natürlich weiter
melden einige das haben wir dann hier im
fernsehen gesehen haben beispielsweise
stunden lang dann in dieser
warteschlange gehangen und wenn sie in
dem moment wo sie dran kamen nicht
aufgepasst haben zu spät geantwortet
haben zack da sind sie rausgeflogen es
wurde einfach aufgelegt und dann mussten
sie sich wieder ein wählen und genau das
passiert jetzt in diesen stunden und
wahrscheinlich auch noch ein ganzes
stück weiter man versucht das was
händisch hoffentlich jedenfalls
aufgeschrieben worden ist in jedem
wahllokal dann tatsächlich hierher zu
melden so dass wir dann irgendwann mal
wissen wer gewonnen hat
annette brieger sammelt fragen von ihnen
und euch ein es gibt so viel zu bereden
woran hat es gelegen was heißt das
eigentlich alles und annette du hast
schon die ersten fragen von unseren
usern bekommen ja und mehrfach
nachgefragt aus der community natürlich
die reaktion des präsidenten vor der
rede zur lage der nation nutzt trump das
auszählung scars der demokraten ja
selbstverständlich das macht donald
trump und wie natürlich per twitter also
donald trump hat sich schon geäußert und
hat gesagt dass das ganze ein
ungebremstes desaster sei so sagt er
nicht nur für die demokraten sondern
auch für das ganze land
er wird dann noch gemein und sagt das
nichts funktioniert bei den demokraten
so wie sie damals eben auch das land
hier geführt haben damit meint er
natürlich die amtszeit von barack obama
und die einzige person die wirklich hier
den großen sieg für sich reklamieren
kann in jever ist trump so hat er es
geschrieben
stimmt ein bisschen weil tatsächlich gab
es ja auch vor wahlen bei der
republikanischen partei
da hatte trump zwei widersacher nämlich
einen früheren gouverneur von
massachusetts und einen früheren
kongressabgeordneten joe walsh und trump
hat mit 97 prozent der stimmen gewonnen
also in der tat auf der republikanischen
seite steht fest bei den demokraten
brachten wir noch was haben wir noch
annette ja und dann ist die frage war
dass menschliches versagen oder war das
doch etwas technisches also konkret kann
man wirklich sicher sein dass das kein
hack war also die demokratische partei
sagt jedenfalls es war kein hack es gibt
keinen hinweis darauf dass das programm
das die app in irgendeiner weise
manipuliert worden ist sondern da ist
einfach offenbar schlecht gearbeitet
worden
so und jetzt ist die große frage diese
ergebnisse müssen jetzt alle einzelnen
per telefon hinein gemeldet werden
und in jedem wahllokal hat man stimmt
karten gehabt auf die dann die einzelnen
wähler ihre stimme vermerkt haben so und
das sind riesige stapel das wurde am
ende ausgezählt und in listen
eingetragen und jetzt ist die große
frage ist das genauso in jedem wahllokal
passiert wenn ja dann würde es jetzt
einfach nur ein paar stunden dauern bis
all die ergebnisse da sind
dann könnte man sagen das sind
ergebnisse wie wir sie schriftlich
festgehalten haben dann kann man sich
wahrscheinlich auch drauf verlassen
aber es ist durchaus vorstellbar dass in
dem ein oder anderen wahllokal chaos
herrschte das vielleicht diese liste
nicht sauber geführt worden ist dass sie
gar nicht existiert und das ist ein
riesenproblem für die demokraten weil
vielleicht dann der eine oder andere
kandidat sagen kann also derjenige der
schlecht abgeschnitten hätte
beispielsweise könnte sagen naja ob das
so alles stimmt und die wirklichkeit
habe ich doch viel besser gelegen also
es ist wirklich ein problem
und in der frage wer hat jetzt
eigentlich gewonnen in dieser ganzen
sache und wer ist der sieger und wie
macht gehen die demokraten weiter voran
gibt es auch noch mehrere mehrfach
nachgefragt wird der community die frage
wie reagieren die anderen demokraten
darauf dass sender sich schon zum sieger
erklärt hat das ist sehr unterschiedlich
also es gibt einerseits die etwas
vorsichtigen wie elisabeth wollen die es
mittlerweile auch wie andere schon
weitergeflogen in den wahlkampf und hat
jetzt bekannt gegeben dass es einfach
viel zu knapp ist das ergebnis als dass
man jetzt sagen könnte liegt man vorne
oder eben nicht
laser vorn lässt im grunde durchsickern
dass es offenbar zwischen ihr bernie
sanders und prodigy dem bürgermeister
von einer stadt in der indianer so eng
ist dass man es eben noch nicht sagen
kann behauptet aber dass joe biden ein
ganzes stück weiter hinten liegt also
auf den vierten platz
die politik hat für sich jetzt schon den
sieg reklamiert denn die einzelnen
kandidaten haben natürlich in allen
wahllokalen auch ihre vertreter gehabt
die mit gezählt und mit aufgeschrieben
haben und auf der basis dessen was die
rückgemeldet haben lässt beat boutique
heute morgen verbreiten dass er wohl in
all diesen wahllokalen wenn man zusammen
rechnet etwa 25 prozent der stimmen
bekommen hat wenn das so wäre so
behauptet jedenfalls sein wahlkampfteam
dann wäre er der gewinner der nacht und
die anderen legen hinter ihm
das wäre natürlich eine sensation weil
die politik hat in den umfragen vorher
eher an dritter oder sogar vierter
stelle meistens gelegen
also wenn er die ford nase vorn hatte
das wäre wirklich eine sensation und
würde das rennen total aufmischen
ja und eigentlich war ja beiden der
große von trainer der favorit und
deswegen noch mal auch die frage von der
community was bedeutet das chaos denn
jetzt eigentlich für beiden also ich
glaube es kommt drauf an ob tatsächlich
die informationen verlässlich sind also
wenn man belegen kann das ist sauber
jetzt noch einmal ausgezählt worden und
joe biden würde auf rang vier landen
dann steht die ganze kampagne also der
wahlkampf von joe biden in frage es kann
gut sein dass innerhalb der
demokratischen partei sich ganz schnell
abzeichnet der hat dann eh keine chance
also die wähler in europa haben ihnen
abgestraft muss wollen wir sagen ist
nicht übermäßig groß hier werden auch
nicht so wahnsinnig viele delegierten
stimmen verteilt für den
landesparteitagen 41 140 delegierten
stimmen insgesamt für den parteitag dann
im sommer also es hat nicht so ein
riesen gewicht aber es spielt eine große
rolle das momentum wie man hier sagt
also ob ein kandidat schwung bekommt und
es gibt so ein spruch der heißt also war
bestimmt zwar nicht die sieger aber
bestimmt die verlierer das heißt wer
hier tatsächlich überraschend schlecht
abschneidet wie vielleicht joe biden der
hat ein problem und das hat sich in den
letzten wochen schon ein bisschen
angedeutet die demokratische partei hat
ihre regeln geändert für die teilnahme
an den fernsehdebatten damit ein
kandidat wie michael bloomberg der
ehemalige bürgermeister von new york
auch an diesen debatten teilnehmen kann
und da deutet sich schon so ein bisschen
an dass man zweifel hatte an joe biden
und dass man einen erfahrenen kandidaten
der etwa moderat auf der gleichen linie
legt wie joe biden dem zumindest eine
chance geben will
also für joe biden wäre es wirklich ein
desaster für die anderen kandidaten also
nehmen wir mal an warren senders budget
schlägen weit vorne
vielleicht auch noch ever closer die
senatorin die aus minnesota kommt also
gleich um die ecke
ich glaube diese vier werden mit schwung
in die nächsten vor wahlen gehen das ist
nur herrscher am nächsten wochenende
dann haben wir nevada wir haben south
carolina
und dann wirst du echt eng für joe biden
und ich finde das auch wichtig jetzt für
die frage wenn die kandidaten nicht nur
die die sich zum sieger küren sondern
auch alle anderen
wenn die jetzt weitergehen die anderen
bundesstaaten ist die frage was passiert
mit areva und eine der fragen der
zuschauer gerd von facebook hat gefragt
muss die vorwahl eventuell wiederholt
werden denn das hätte ich ja riesige
konsequenzen auch für die die jetzt nur
in die nächsten bundesstaaten gehen soll
ja es ist kaum vorstellbar dass man
diese vor weil ihr wiederholt das ist ja
im grunde ganz komplexer prozess dass
die menschen dann in diese wahllokale
strömen in die turnhallen in die cafés
und und dann eben sehr kompliziert
ausgezählt wird ich glaube das wird
nicht passieren man wird ein ergebnis
veröffentlichen vielleicht unter
vorbehalt stellen und dann parkt man das
ab und es wird vielleicht dann auf dem
parteitag hier in ios selber der ist den
wenigen wochen wird dann entschieden
werden wie man wirklich die delegierten
stimmen verteilt da hat man auch ein
bisschen möglichkeiten noch was zu
verändern hat man in der vergangenheit
auch gemacht aber es wäre ein desaster
für die demokratische partei in iowa
man hat sich immer damit geschickt
geschmückt dass man der erste ist in der
kette hatte beim letzten mal 2016 schon
probleme und jetzt wieder so dass
vielleicht die frage gestellt wird warum
eigentlich vor allen anderen und die
sollen sich doch bitte einreihen und
vielleicht erst am super tuesday das ist
der tag im märz an dem in einer mehr als
ein dutzend bundesstaaten in den usa die
vor wahlen stattfinden so dass er seine
ich sag mal ganz besondere stellung
verlieren könnte und die frage wie es
weitergeht ist natürlich steht im raum
wann erfahren wir was david es auch von
youtube fragt sind denn schon hoch
rechnungsergebnisse vorhanden
es gibt keine hoch rechnungsergebnisse
die wären ja quasi offiziell das einzige
was es gibt dass die kandidaten selber
eben durch das was ihre anhänger
berichten aus den verschiedenen
wahllokalen irgendwo alles schön
zusammen schreiben und addieren und
hoffen dass sie dann tatsächlich die
sieger sind wir wissen tatsächlich nicht
wann das offizielle ergebnis kommt es
hat in der vergangen
danach dann ein telefongespräch gegeben
noch eine telefonkonferenz der
offiziellen vertreter der demokratischen
partei die für die ausstellung
verantwortlich sind mit den vertretern
der einzelnen kandidaten da ist es hoch
hergegangen offenbar hat der vertreter
von bernie sanders sich heftig angelegt
mit dem offiziellen demokratischen
partei dass die das nicht auf die reihe
kriegen die ergebnisse hierzu melden
und dann wurde einfach diese konferenz
kurzerhand beendet also ich weiß hier
keiner um wie viel uhr in algerien die
man die ergebnisse verkündet werden wir
hoffen dass das innerhalb ich sag mal
den nächsten drei vier stunden passiert
aber dann wird man uns auch offenlegen
müssen auf welcher basis denn eigentlich
diese ergebnisse zustande gekommen sind
und wenn ich jetzt noch mal die nächsten
fragen durchlese die hier reingekommen
sind dann stellt sich natürlich die
frage die sich auch eine zuschauer auf
youtube gestellt hat haben die
demokraten gegen jump denn überhaupt
eine chance ja das ist natürlich die
spannendste frage wie hat auch viele
wähler jetzt in der vergangenen nacht
hier bewegt geht es in erster linie
darum jemanden zu finden der die besten
chancen gegen donald trump hat
oder geht es darum jemanden zu finden
der die ideen am glaubhaftesten die
themen am glaubhaftesten vertritt
innerhalb der demokratischen partei und
wenn man den umfragen glauben darf dies
dann parallel zu diesen korpus
veranstaltungen gegeben hat dann ist die
überwältigende mehrheit der demokraten
der meinung wichtiger ist wer hat eine
chance gegen donald trump zu gewinnen
und das verrückte ist dass es eine
landesweite umfrage gibt aus den letzten
tagen von nbc und wall street journal
die sehr klar gesagt dass die kandidaten
joe biden bonnie centers allan und pete
warden tatsächlich im nationalen
vergleich bei den wahlen vor trump legen
also tatsächlich eine chance haben ihn
zu schlagen und das ist etwas was den
demokraten natürlich mut macht sie
wissen wenn sie es schaffen möglichst
viele wähler dann an die wahlurnen zu
bekommen im november
egal welcher von den genannten jetzt
dann der kandidat ist dann haben sie
wirklich eine chance gegen donald trump
aber nur und das ist wichtig wenn sie
sich
alle hinter einem kandidaten dann
versammeln der im sommer auf dem
parteitag der demokraten dominiert wird
wir hatten bei der letzten wahl 2016
jahren die situation dass eigentlich ein
anderer nominiert worden ist und bernie
sanders also hillary clinton wurde
nominiert und bernie sanders hat einfach
naja mit halbem herzen sie unterstützt
nicht so wirklich und man hatte das
gefühl er will unbedingt trotzdem
weitermachen das ergebnis war dass wir
alle wissen donald trump hat gewonnen
hillary clinton hat verloren also die
demokratische partei steht unter einem
riesigen druck dass sich alle hinter
einer kandidatin oder einen kandidaten
dann im sommer versammelt das beispiel
von boenigk senders fand ich auch ganz
interessant
wir haben immer wieder gefragt die
wähler wenn also die die unterstützung
von boenigk senders wenn er es nicht
werden sollte wenn eine andere kandidat
zum favoriten gekürt wird können sie
sich vorstellen für einen anderen
zustimmen und sagten sie es kommt darauf
an wenn wir das gefühl haben dass bernie
nicht so dass das ganze nicht mit
rechten dingen zugegangen ist und bernie
eigentlich vielleicht doch bessere
chancen gehabt hätten dann werden wir
uns nicht hinter andere kandidaten
stellen und so ein technisches problem
wie wir das jetzt sehen wenn es denn ein
technisches war ist natürlich das große
problem dass dann die glaubwürdigkeit
der kandidat in frage
und das ist gerade wegen des senders ein
großes problem seine anhänger sind
glaube ich noch eine andere kategorie
als anhänger von elisabeth in englischer
und wie sie alle heißen die deren
anhänger mit denen wir ja auch
gesprochen haben in den letzten zwei
tagen die signalisieren wichtig ist das
ziel trump aus dem amt zu entfernen also
versammeln wir uns hinter auch einem
anderen kandidaten aber bei bernie
sanders anhängern ist das schwierig das
sind glühende eiferer teilweise
jedenfalls sind vor allen dingen sehr
sehr viele junge leute und es kommt bei
der wahl sicherlich auch darauf an wie
viele von den jungen leuten auch die die
zum ersten mal wählen gehen wirklich
dann an die wahlurnen und die werden
gebraucht wenn breunig senders nicht
kandidat ist dass sie sich eben auch für
den anderen engagieren also das dürfte
dann spannend werden in den nächsten
monaten
das ganze ist ja ein bisschen
kompliziert jetzt gibt es ein statement
von auf facebook von hp
ich finde die wahlen in usa sehr
kompliziert in deutschland ist es viel
einfacher
sie sollen deutschland als vorbild
nehmen dann gibt es auch kein chaos ist
vielleicht was trage ja da ist glaube
ich ein bisschen was dran oder fiel
sogar wir haben jetzt zum beispiel schon
new hampshire am nächsten wochenende
und da ist das system ein ganz anderes
als hier in iowa während man hier eben
drauf gesetzt hat dass das gewissermaßen
aus diskutiert wird in diesen
veranstaltungen diesem korpus wird die
new hampshire ganz klassisch abgestimmt
da muss man schriftlich seine seine
stimme abgeben das wird ordentlich
gezählt da gibt es kontrolleure und
aufseher die das alles mitschreiben die
das alles überprüfen so dass man sich
auf das ergebnis von new hampshire dann
auch sehr gut verlassen kann
also es ist wirklich ein problem und ich
bei den 90er jahren ja hier schon mal
korrespondent in den usa fürs zdf und
habe damals erlebt wie george bush gegen
ergo angetreten ist es war das super
chaos überhaupt das war das super chaos
weil hier ja noch mit wahlmaschinen und
auch heute noch mit waren maschinen
teilweise gewählt wird wo man in den
stimmzettel ein loch hinein stechen muss
es mit so einem kleinen spitzen stift
und wer nicht ordentlich zusticht in
diesen wahlmaschinen da kann es dann
passieren dass diese stimmzettel nur ein
bisschen ausgebeult sind oder leicht
angerissen sind an der stelle wo man
eigentlich sein kreuzchen machen müsste
in deutschland würde man einfach sein
kreuzchen machen und dann haben wir ja
die situation damals erlebt dass in
florida noch einmal neu ausgezählt wurde
unter saßen dann tatsächlich die
mitarbeiter von von dem staat florida
dann da und haben diese stimmzettel
gegenlicht gehalten um zu sehen ist
jetzt ein loch da drin und hat der kann
hat tatsächlich der wähler versuch
diesen kandidaten zu wählen
also musste so ein bisschen die absicht
des wählers interpretieren
also es ist schon ein etwas an titel
antiquierte system das interessante
finde ich aber es war ja damals 2000 der
beginn der wahlmaschinen die eingesetzt
werden wurden
und damals hat man schon erkannt wie
wichtig ist ist dass es einen so
genannten paper trail gibt also dass man
nicht nur das ergebnis aus dem maschinen
hat sondern dass man auch ein ganz
normales traditionelles stück papier hat
wo der wunsch des wählers verzeichnet
wurde
und hier ist das hier jetzt wieder
ähnlich dass man eine ganz moderne ab
auf die handys der einzelnen
bezirksleiter gesetzt hat mit der sie
schnell und effizient kommunizieren
sollten das hat nicht funktioniert und
jetzt ist wieder die große frage gibt es
denn von den einzelnen abstimmungen
tatsächlich auch diesen paper trail ein
stück papier wo sie ganz traditionellen
aufgeschrieben haben
das war mein wohl schon recht ich gerne
habe und es gibt es in der tat ist sind
einige technische innovation sagen wir
mal gekommen dass man in die
wahlmaschine sein kreuz im grunde um ein
gibt oder einfach drückt auf den
bildschirm und abstimmt und dann bekommt
nicht nur aus der maschine direkt weiter
gemeldet
die zentrale das ergebnis sondern jeder
wähler bekommt tatsächlich einen kleinen
ausdruck in die hand auf dem daneben zu
lesen ist was er gewählt hat
aber diese wahl maschinen werden nicht
flächendeckend in den usa eingesetzt und
jeder bundesstaat kann das für sich
entscheiden und so werden wir
wahrscheinlich bei der wahl im november
in den bundesstaaten ein
ich sage mal relativ verlässliches
system haben und in den anderen
bundesstaaten ein system wo man denkt
das kann nicht wahr sein bei so einer
demokratie wie die vereinigten staaten
von amerika
da habe ich jetzt noch mal eine frage
von youtube die auch mehrfach gestellt
wurde
du hast es schon kurz angedeutet aber
nochmal die entscheidend sind solche
vorwahlen also nicht nur hier in euro
aber wie entscheidend sind solche
vorwahlen denn überhaupt die vorwahlen
sind ja eben deshalb wichtig weil dabei
die delegierten stimmen für den
parteitag im sommer bestimmt werden also
jetzt eben 41 stimmen hier aussah
die dann im juli wenn die demokraten
ihren parteitag haben einfließen in die
wahl des tatsächlichen kandidaten
es gibt bundesstaaten wie texas florida
kalifornien die haben ja viel mehr die
haben hunderte von delegiertenstimmen
im sommer und dann auf diesem parteitag
wird mit hilfe dieser delegiertenstimmen
am ende eben bestimmt wird es joe biden
wird das speedboot digitales bewahren
wer auch immer also es ist schon wichtig
weil in manchen bundesstaaten auch dann
tatsächlich die ergebnisse oder in
vielen sogar die ergebnisse
verpflichtend sind das heißt das was
hier rauskommen
das bringt der bundesstaat florida
daneben auch in diesen parteitag mit ein
und man kann sich nicht mal eben so
einfach und so entscheiden sondern ist
gebunden
aber es gibt auch für die bundesstaaten
mit anderen regeln dh wo im sommer
vielleicht alles wieder um gekippt wird
und manche sprechen dann von einem
sogenannten brokat convention dh es kann
passieren was das bei der demokratischen
partei weil sich die delegierten stimmen
aufteilen unter ich sag mal drei oder
vier kandidaten
dass man also keinen klaren gewinner hat
und so dass auf diesem parteitag selber
dann im juli hinter den kulissen und
offen verhandelt wird und man versucht
so wie bei den irak ist es die anderen
noch rüberzuziehen ins eigene lager und
man dann aus handelt wir haben ende der
kandidat der demokratischen partei seien
und das war ja von anfang an selbst vor
diesen technischen chaos schon die sorge
hier immer dass es nicht einen klaren
sieger gibt oder zwei klare sieger es
muss ja nicht immer nur eine person das
große glück haben aber dass es immer
eine unentschiedene situation bleibt und
da gibt es jetzt auch noch mal die frage
von robin von facebook wenn werden sich
die demokraten wirklich hinter einer
person versammeln können also wenn es
jetzt auch wirklich so viele
interessante köpfe weiter bleibt der
einen die eine frage wäre werden sich
die demokraten wirklich hinter einer
person versammeln können senders oder
wollen oder irgendeinen anderen
moderaten kann dass die partei nicht
spalten und das sind natürlich zwei
entscheidende fragen ob dahinter
verbergen absolut also das ist natürlich
kaffeesatzleserei aber nach dem was wir
hören von experten hier in den usa jetzt
nicht nur in europa sondern auch
anderswo ist eine spaltung der partei
eher unwahrscheinlich weil man weiß was
auf dem spiel steht man weiß dass man
eigentlich dafür sorgen will dass donald
trump eben nicht wiedergewählt
doch weil die demokraten glauben und das
tun glaube ich die anhänger aller
kandidaten und die kandidatin aus selber
dass donald trump das land wenn er vier
jahre weiter regiert noch soweit weiter
verändern wird dass man die
amerikanische demokratie nicht mehr
wiedererkennen wird und das einst so ein
bisschen auch die kandidaten wenn man
sie sich genauer ansieht dann sind sie
sich alle einig dass man muss eine
veränderung herbeiführen politisch in
diesem land und allen geht es auch darum
etwas zu verändern was glaube ich das
größte problem hier in den usa ist
nämlich fehlende gerechtigkeit und zwar
soziale und wirtschaftliche
gerechtigkeit es gibt einen tiefen
graben in amerika zwischen den reichen
und den armen und er ist in den letzten
20 30 jahren immens gewachsen willmann
beispiel nennen seit den siebziger
jahren ist das einkommen der
superreichen der 0,1 reichsten in den
0,1 prozent reisten in den usa um 223
prozent gestiegen dieses einkommen und
das einkommen für jemanden aus der
mittelklasse ist in diesem zeitraum nur
um 41 prozent gestiegen
und da sieht man dass diese kluft immer
größer geworden ist und alle kandidaten
sind sich einig das muss sich ändern das
darf so nicht weitergehen
und da empfehlen einige wie bönisch
senders eine umverteilung des geldes und
des wohlstands in den usa und zwar mit
programmen die schon sehr revolutionär
teilweise klingen auch elisabeth wollen
sie hat für alles einen plan und und und
schließt oder oder schlägt sehr
drastische maßnahmen vor da sind pete
bodycheck lovato und joe biden
ich sag mal moderator unterwegs und
wollen nicht die revolution sie wollen
schrittweise die ungerechtigkeit in
amerika beseitigen aber ich glaube der
kern ist sie wollen die ungerechtigkeit
beseitigen und das birgt ein oder gibt
eine große chance dass man sich dann
hinter einem kandidaten auf versammelt
vielleicht noch als letzte frage als
letzte frage noch weil du das auch
gerade angesprochen hast gerade bei den
jungen wählern es ja der frage der um
die frage der ungerechtigkeit besonders
wird besonders intensiv gestellt und da
ist dann die frage von von hu sehr hell
auf youtube erreichen die älteren
kandidaten wie zum beispiel des senders
überhaupt die jungen wähler und senders
ist ja der die frage der sozialen
ungerechtigkeit am intensivsten und am
kontroversesten vielleicht auch
anspricht
ja ich glaube die jungen wähler machen
sich ja besonders viel sorgen und auch
zu recht um die zukunft das ist ihre
zukunft sie werden mal das land im
grunde genommen leiten und mitbestimmen
was in diesem land passiert in den
nächsten zehn 20 30 jahren würde nichts
anders spricht viele junge leute an weil
sie sich sorgen machen um die
gerechtigkeit sie machen sich sorgen um
den klimawandel
aber wir haben ja in den letzten tagen
auf der einen oder anderen veranstaltung
hier bei den kandidaten auch erlebt da
waren auch bei joe biden nicht nur die
älteren vertreten da waren auch viele
jüngere dabei auch bei pit budde gp ein
38-jähriger bürgermeister der
möglicherweise hier gut abgeschnitten
hatte in europa also ich glaube dass
auch die jungen sich für andere
begeistern können als bernie sanders und
das ist sehr wichtig weil sie stellen am
ende auch die freiwilligen die dann
nachher von tür zu tür gehen im
wahlkampf und klingeln und versuchen für
ihren kandidaten zu werben damit donald
trump eben nicht wiedergewählt wird
also es wird sehr spannend glaube ich
kann man sagen es bleibt hier in are war
sehr spannend hoffentlich in ein paar
stunden werden wir genauer wissen wie es
denn hier ausgegangen ist und wir werden
natürlich berichten weiter auf der heute
de wir berichten natürlich auch in
unsere nachrichtensendungen und werden
auch in den nächsten tagen und wochen im
wahlkampf immer wieder die gelegenheit
suchen ihre und eure fragen zu
beantworten herzlichen dank lieber nette
für die fragen und das gespräch lieben
dank an sie liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern userinnen und user und wir
wünschen ihnen von hier aus einen
schönen tag noch